there are more than 600 muscles in the
human body
but if you're training for a main role
on riverdale only a small fraction of
those
really matter the chest shoulders and
abdominal v-cut
which stars like kj apa sculpt to look
great on camera
every role has its physical demands
whether it's all about aesthetics
acrobatics size or strength
let's take a look at the highly
customized training programs of
seven actors preparing for intensely
physical roles
michael b jordan is pretty much always
in great shape
but the body he sculpts in training
depends on the character he's getting
ready to play
the actor was fresh off his role as
adonis in creed
when he started gearing up to play
killmonger in black panther
both are very physical roles but they're
also very different
one is a boxing hero the other a super
villain
plus killmonger was michael's first time
playing a bad guy
so he had to do everything he could to
get in the character's head
and body michael's longtime trainer
corey kaye
said all these factors helped shape his
client's regimen
for michael to play adonis corey said
the goal was to get
lean lean lean the program involved a
lot of running
and surprise boxing but while the actors
creed training was all about getting
cut his black panther training was all
about getting
big michael and corey wanted to build a
body that would surprise people
so using the foundation he built for
creed michael ditched his high cardio
routine for intense weight training
built around
curls squats and bench presses corey is
also michael's nutritionist
and for black panther he had his client
eating five to six meals a day on a
carb-heavy diet that included lots of
potatoes
eggs bacon and chicken this helped
michael fill out his upper body and
ultimately add 15 pounds of muscle to
his frame
but right after black panther he headed
back into the ring for creed 2
which meant he and corey had to bring
back adonis all over again
each avenger has their own set of skills
natasha romanovs are her martial arts
when scarlett johansson landed the role
in 2009 she enlisted celebrity trainer
eric johnson to turn her into the deadly
assassin we see in the avengers movies
the first part of scarlet's training was
all about mobility
many of black widow's signature moves
are spider-inspired
like this leg twist attack where she
wraps her leg around the neck of her
opponent
that's a pretty high kick eric says and
it requires a lot of hip mobility and
hip flexor strength
he had scarlett do 90 90 hip swivels so
she could perform the move explosively
the second stage of her training was
aimed at building power
eric had scarlett doing a 245 pound
deadlift
and single leg pistol squats in this
phase of the training
that power translates on screen and
black widow's kicks and punches
like here in this scene from captain
america civil war
a lot of people think punches only come
from the arms or the upper body
but eric says that if you want to
produce power it has to come from the
ground
all the way up to that fist the third
and final phase
was geared toward getting scarlet at
peak conditioning level
this phase refined some aesthetic
aspects of scarlet's performance
for one eric had scarlett practice her
recovery after an intense set
gaining control of her breathing and
getting her heart rate down as fast as
possible
so that she could better control her
face on camera
after all she couldn't afford to have a
pain face on when playing black widow
she needed to look as poised and
controlled as a superhero would
if black widow's strength lies in her
punches and kicks spider-man's lies in
his agility and acrobatics
luckily tom holland has a background as
a dancer and
gymnast tom said he had to audition
eight times to play spider-man
and his athleticism ultimately helped
land him the role
even with his solid foundation though
tom had to train hard in preparation for
his first
solo marvel film spider-man homecoming
after all his acrobatics had to look
super human which meant convincingly
climbing walls
doing wild flips and slinging webs
through the city
here tom's following his stunt double
holland diaz and doing a side somersault
off a mini trampoline
followed by a big kick out and a perfect
left foot landing
when he wasn't in the gymnasium tom kept
his training up with an air track mat
a giant inflatable and portable piece of
equipment that's kind of like a spring
floor bouncy castle and tumbling and
landing that all wrapped up into one
he used this to practice his twists
flips
and side somersaults tom was determined
to do most of his own stunts
but he had to do crossfit style circuit
workouts to make sure he could work day
in
and day out on set to sharpen his spidey
reflexes
tom went through extensive martial arts
and combat training
here he is again with his stunt double
working on his hand-eye coordination
and then there was the question of
aesthetics filling out the spidey suit
and looking good out of the suit too one
of tom's trainers george ashwell said
the shirtless scene in the script
motivated tom to add 14 pounds of muscle
to his frame
the actor did sets of chin-ups to build
up his chest tom shared this photo with
marvel trainer duffy gaver on their last
workout day
showing off his body in peak spidey
shape
riverdale has been known for its
shirtless scenes from the beginning
but season 3 brought a new challenge for
star kj appa whose character archie
goes from high school football jock to
prison boxer
given the number of bare-chested fight
scenes he'd have to appear in
kj decided to step up his fitness
routine under the guidance of
alex fine the riverdale cast's secret
weapon
after getting a start doing strength
conditioning for nfl stars like odell
beckham jr
reggie bush and marshawn lynch alex went
on to train kj
charles melton cole sprouse camila
mendes casey cott
bart denton and mark consuelos actors
are different from athletes he says
for guys like kj or charles who plays
reggie on the show
alex will pay special attention to the
top of the chest and shoulders
since those areas are the most
noticeable on camera
for season three alex incorporated high
intensity cardio into kj's weight
training to help him get a lean waist
he had kj doing two 90-minute workouts a
day often they tackle cardio in the
morning and then do weights in the
afternoon
beyond basic weightlifting alex says
clients like kj do a lot of bodyweight
exercises
including sit ups planks push-ups
pull-ups and chin holes
this regimen has the advantage of using
minimal gym equipment
basically a prison cell workout alex
says
creating a bigger chest and leaner waist
gets clients like kj
closer to one of the aesthetic goals for
riverdale stars
sculpting that v-cut also known as the
sex lines
that's the deep v-shaped cut where the
lower abs and obliques meet
this is one role where vanity muscles
maybe
are the most important thing
bob odenkirk was a comedy writer for 25
years before
starring as tv's favorite lawyer a
decidedly
non-action role but at age 58 he starred
in his first ever action movie
nobody bob got a head start on bringing
out the fighter within
he started training for nobody before
the film was even greenlit
it's standard for an actor to train for
four to six
weeks for a role bob trained for two
years
as a guy in his 50s bob wanted to avoid
getting sidelined by an injury
for that reason his trainer stunt actor
daniel bernhardt
said that intense weight training like
lifting a heavy bench press
was not on the table instead bob's
training was all about
movement daniel gave him a crash course
in screen fighting based on the concept
of hip rotation
according to daniel fighting is all
about how you turn your hips when you
throw a punch
when you take a reaction for bob
learning to activate his hips
helped blast his core and provide him
with the explosive punch power he needed
for the bus fight in nobody
director ilya nae schuler wanted bob to
fight like a wolverine in that scene
the goal was for him to pull off 99 of
his own stunts so they wouldn't have to
use
fast-paced editing to hide bob's
mistakes or stunt replacements
that allowed ilya to get longer takes
that made the fight feel more visceral
and realistic
in the end it was okay for bob's
fighting skills to be rough around the
edges
that's because the bus fight is the
first time we see hutch transform back
into his fighter self
so his character is actually supposed to
look a little rusty
in the making and that's only the fight
bob odenkirk went from average to action
hero but what about becoming a
superhero that's what brie larson had to
do when she signed on to play one of the
most
powerful avengers for her standalone
movie captain marvel
free's character had to look believable
engaging her enemies in hand-to-hand
combat atop a moving train
the only problem brees started her
career in
indie roles and said she was never
particularly active before taking on the
role of carol danvers
at the beginning of training she
couldn't even do a proper push-up or
pull-up for her initial fitness
inspiration she looked to emily blunt
who got jacked for edge of tomorrow so
that she could safely wear a
70-pound exoskeleton bree sought out
emily's trainer jason walsh and with him
planned out a nine-month training
schedule
much of which would take place as brie
was shooting avengers end game
brie's body kept getting more taut as
training went on
forcing the costume team for captain
marvel to adjust her suit
more than once the staples of her
program included hip thrusts
split squats and the dreaded push-ups
and pull-ups
jason rarely has his clients use
machines but he and bree did get
creative with other equipment
like these weighted chains which they
wrapped around bree's torso to make her
push-up sets even more challenging
or jason's own car he said brie got it
in her head early on that she'd get
strong enough to push
jason's jeep with her bare hands and by
the end of training
she did for a full 60 seconds
so basically real life superhero stunts
the physicality brie achieved through
her transformation helped her
performance
but so did the mentality one of jason's
goals was to get brie as close as
humanly possible to the psychology of a
superhero
who was pretty much invincible in the
end he said
having that physical strength helped her
become the character
it wasn't painless jason said there were
points where he made brie cry
in the gym
when jennifer lopez and constance wu
played strippers and hustlers
they couldn't fall back on body doubles
for the pole dancing scenes
the film didn't use any which meant both
actors had to get
pole ready it was okay for constance wu
to look a little less experienced on the
pole
after all her character destiny is
supposed to be a newbie
j-lo on the other hand plays ramona a
veteran stripper at the club who takes
destiny under her wing
to fit this dynamic there had to be a
clear contrast between destiny's
beginner skills
and ramona's mastery of the poll
in other words j-lo had to nail it
she had danced before of course on tour
and in movies like shall we dance
but pole dancing is a whole different
ball game
it requires certain muscle groups to be
super strong
and no small amount of acrobatics that's
where pole choreographer johanna sepaki
came in
a former aerial acrobat in cirque du
soleil johanna designed
all the pole dancing scenes and hustlers
including ramona's
main routine which clocked in at 4
minutes long
jlo would have to do multiple takes of
that dance at different angles
getting it right every time to meet the
challenge the actor moved a portable
pole into each of her houses in new york
city
la and miami so that she could practice
all the time
johanna started her training with
climbing and basic spins
laying down the main principles of pole
dancing after that it took a while for
j.lo to develop a fast
smooth rotation on the pole spinning can
be disorienting at first
even if you're an experienced dancer
like j-lo as johanna explained
when you're a dancer you spin on top of
yourself as a pole dancer you're like a
carousel
going around a fixed point the last
thing to master was the inverted
splits this was supposed to be the one
big wow moment in ramona's routine
where she flips upside down on the pole
and supports her whole body with just
her arms and shoulders
inverting and then keeping that position
on the pole takes a lot of core strength
a lot of upper body strength and an
excellent grip
at first johanna would spot jlo as she
practiced pulling herself
up after two months of training though
jlo was comfortably doing
upside down splits on her own the actor
said that learning the pole dance was
one of the hardest things i've ever had
to do for a role
you